let's start with the first topic compute  options in the cloud  Google Cloud offers a variety of compute  Services spanning different usage  options  for General workloads that require  dedicated resources for your  applications compute engine is a good  option  and if you're looking for a platform as  a service app engine is a good option  Cloud functions offers a serverless  option for triggered code to run based  on some kind of event  to run containers on a managed  kubernetes platform you can leverage  Google kubernetes engine  and Cloud run is a fully managed  serverless platform that lets you  develop and deploy highly scalable  containerized applications  you'll explore each of these compute  Services during this module